foreign
[Music]
good afternoon everyone I'm very excited
to introduce our next keynote speaker
Joe Chang the CTO of our studio and uh
since Joe is talking about shiny I
thought I'd introduce him with a little
story a personal story about shiny
and as many of you know I wrote the book
mastering shining you might think well
why did Hedley write that and not Joe
so Joe came to me I don't know like four
or five years ago and said hey like I
want to write a book about shiny what
should I do and so I gave him my book
writing advice which is writing a book's
really easy all you need to do is write
for an hour a day for a year and at the
end of the year you'll have that book
now as far as I know no one has
successfully followed that advice so
it's provably terrible advice and uh
after my advice failed for Joe for some
time I kind of took pity on him and said
oh hey I I love writing books like I'll
write it for you and I kind of cut to
the end of the story I wrote mastering
shiny and to say thank you Joe built me
a bike which is the most amazing bicycle
that I've like ever ridden in my life
and it seemed to me just like this
perfect example of a win-win like I got
all of the pleasure of writing a book
and I didn't have to build a bicycle
myself and uh Joe got all the pleasure
of building me a bike and didn't have to
write a book so please welcome Joe ching
thank you so much
Hadley
[Applause]
but that's less funny after he told that
beautiful story about the bike I feel
kind of bad now
July 31st 2012.
was the day that we first showed shiny
to the world
we were at JSM not even a scheduled talk
Brian Lewis just lent US 10 minutes at
the end of his talk and we showed shiny
and if you consider that date July 31st
to be the birth of shiny
then this is a particularly special talk
for me to give to you today
because that means that shiny is 10
years old
10 years
it's hard to believe
so to to mark this anniversary
um I thought I'd do things a little bit
different this time than usual
I usually focus on what's coming what's
new and I wanted to take this
opportunity to talk a little bit about
how shiny started
and the story of how shiny started
really begins
with Danny Kaplan
oh yeah some Danny fans in the audience
[Applause]
um Danny and his students at McAllister
College were the very first beta testers
of our studio IDE
[Music]
this is going way better than I thought
it would
uh and Danny's feedback was so great his
fingerprints are all over the IDE even
to this day you can see all the parts
that he influenced with his feedback
and in early 2011 Danny asked JJ for a
way to build interactive apps in r that
he could use to demonstrate statistical
and uh and calculus Concepts
and JJ being JJ
uh in about a week he built this
this is the manipulate feature in
rstudio
sort of the uh Proto shiny if you will
and manipulate was great because or is
great because it almost couldn't be
simpler this is how manipulate works
you give it some kind of
plot generating function or plot
generating expression
and include one or more Unbound
variables that you want the user to be
able to control
then for each of those
you describe how you want that to appear
so there are a couple of there's slider
and there's a look up a couple of things
like that
and
this worked great and Danny ran with it
and created uh quite a few really
beautifully uh thought out and assembled
tiny applets that uh Illustrated these
Concepts
and he bundled them together as part of
this project mosaic
now it wasn't long
as tends to happen with software it
wasn't long before some questions
started
boy it sure would be nice to have a
customizable layout can I have those
inputs show up in two columns for
example could I have more input types
maybe multiple outputs at once instead
of just one plot maybe different kinds
of outputs like tables and maybe instead
of just showing things we could also
take some actions when the user clicked
a button or something like that
and finally
why do people have to be using rstudio
IDE to use these applets it would be
great to be able to take these little
interactive things and move them out
all of those totally reasonable totally
reasonable
great suggestions
and
what he was describing was a full
interactive UI framework
now that was something that JJ and I
clearly had the technical ability to
create
but I felt really strongly this is not
something that we should do this felt
like a trap to me
because UI programming sucks
this is how I honestly felt in 2012. I
had spent a lot of my career writing
complex uis
and the reason it sucks is because of
this idiom called event handlers this is
the way all UI worked in those days
the way you I the way event handlers
work is so simple I can explain it to
you right now
the idea is this when X happens
do I
in this example X being that some text
box has changed
and in response we want to do Y which is
update the text of this status label to
some new value
very very simple
the problem is when you have multiple of
these in your UI they become hard to
reason about similar to Global variables
if you've ever been warmed off of
programming with extensive use of global
variables it's the reasoning that
becomes hard
and this is a huge problem because as
your UI gets more complex and the logic
gets more complex it starts requiring
extremely high levels of skill and
discipline to do well it can be done
clearly we've had complex uis for a long
time but it really is deceptively
difficult and takes the most disciplined
and talented engineers
and if you don't get it quite right if
you don't have that level of skill and
discipline you end up with bugs and not
just normal bugs like freezing and
errors but more pernicious ones like an
app confidently giving you an answer
that's incorrect
and that's bad enough in a normal piece
of consumer software but to inflict that
onto the r community
to put the tools into their hands to
confidently get the wrong answer
uh it was unconscionable
so we didn't do it
and the problem was as much as I hated
event handlers
I couldn't come up with not only a
better alternative but any alternative I
had been doing this kind of programming
day in day out for years
constantly thinking there must be a
better way than this
and I could not even conceive of a
better way
until around May oh
May of 2012 sorry there's a lot of dates
in this talk
in May of 2012 I watched a screencast
for a brand new web framework called
meteor
and this was the craziest thing I'd ever
seen it blew me away
there were so many ideas in meteor that
they were demonstrating in their code
that
felt like alien technology to me or like
a magic trick
one particular magic trick among many
just stuck itself in my brain and I
couldn't dislodge it and it was this
like any other web framework meteor had
a way for you to have templates you
would write some HTML markup and in the
middle you would throw in some dynamic
dynamic value like a name
and this is where in a traditional web
framework you would then attach an event
handler to make sure that that template
was re-rendered at the appropriate time
but the media guy said this verbatim
I changed the data and the template
updates there's no event handlers it
just works and he said it like that
and I was like
there's no event handlers it just works
what like
how how does that just work
and that was me I mean for like days and
maybe a week or two after
I couldn't shake this thought how do
they do that
and the only thing I could think of is
maybe they just re-execute everything
every time something changes they just
re-execute all of their templates but
that didn't seem to be
what they were talking about
finally I couldn't take it anymore
I just went and Googled how does meteor
work don't worry you're not supposed to
be able to see the code here but there
was a sack overflow answer that pointed
to this file and said this is how it
works
and I just include the screenshot so
that you can see how short it is
71 lines of code
with pretty copious comments
so I downloaded the meteor repo onto my
laptop and got on a plane ride home from
a conference and I told myself
by the time I get off this plane I'm
gonna understand how this works
and I did
uh it's it's actually pretty
straightforward once you know the trick
it's simple it's elegant
and it felt to me like maybe these guys
are onto something this is actually the
better way to do this not just a trick
but a genuinely new way to do things and
I was very impressed loved it super
satisfying to find out how it worked
and then I closed my laptop and I don't
know watched a movie or something
no dots were connected that day shiny
was not born that day
in fact it was almost a month later
when it finally hit me and the way it
hit me was a little weird
I swear this is true this has never
happened to me before since
that morning I woke up
I opened my eyes and the very first
conscious thought in my head was an
entire web framework
yeah that's not a joke that literally is
what happened
and I will show you literally
what it looked like
it started with a simple HTML interface
the most important thing was you weren't
going to have to write any JavaScript as
an app developer all you had to do is
write HTML tags and include IDs and
classes that would indicate where inputs
and outputs were
and what they were called
and we would power that
with reactive server logic using that
trick from meteor
all you'd have to do is explain how an
output is to be created based on these
input values and shiny would take care
of knowing when to you guys know how it
works okay
and then a websocket connection to tie
them both together and this what I'm
showing that was the first thought in my
brain when I woke up that morning
it felt like a gift
but the weirdest thing about that
morning
wasn't necessarily the completeness of
this Vision uh it was the timing
this is this is terrifying I've never
told this story in public uh but I
thought it was
um a thing that I really wanted to share
with you now
that day June 15 2012 was supposed to be
my last day at our studio
um
that spring I was just feeling
like my voice is terrifying
um
that spring I was feeling like my career
had plateaued
I was a software engineer in my mid-30s
um
I love the work that JJ and I were doing
together but it was just the two of us
and all around I looked at my classmates
and people that I had been peers with at
past companies and I saw them starting
companies
and riding rocket ships you know uh up
the corporate ranks at the biggest tech
companies and just doing the most
amazing things that I would read about
in the news
and I was deathly afraid of being left
behind
and I felt
like in order for me to feel like I was
a success I was going to need to start
my own company
so I went to JJ
I mean I've been with JJ for a long time
and I opened up to him about how I was
feeling and he said to me
I totally understand and if that's what
you want to do
I will support you I'll help you however
I can
but this was in the run-up to use our we
were trying to get our mark down off the
ground
uh he had a had a keynote
so
my commitment to him was I'm going to
fully focus on our studio
until use ours over and as soon as youth
R is over I'm going to go on leave and
think about my future and if all went
well
I'd never come back from that leave
the last day of uzar
what did I say June 15th 2012. it was
that day it was that day is my point
what was supposed to be my last day
at our studio
and in the blink of an eye
when this appeared in my brain
it was like a light switch was flipped
and all those feelings I had all the
fear and insecurity
were just erased in an instant
and I was
completely consumed by this curiosity of
would this work can we build this
and just filled with this Creative Drive
to see this happen
and I tell the story because I want you
to understand
how profound a gift really this was the
first of many profound gifts that shiny
gave to me I was about to make a pretty
big life and career decision
uh that I think would have been a
mistake because I was making it out of
fear and out of insecurity
and what shiny gave me was something to
run towards with curiosity
with creativity
and it's just been such a magical 10
years I wouldn't trade it for anything
oh my gosh okay now
I took this sketch you know jotted it
down and ran down to find JJ you know we
were at uzar
and I showed him I was like
look at this
and he immediately got it I mean
instantly he was like this is it this is
what you work on from now on forget
everything else you're working on this
and he just requested one change it took
him some time to convince me
he said why are we making people write
HTML
and I was like I'm saving them from
JavaScript they can learn HTML
[Applause]
uh but he was pretty insistent and he
was very right and what we ended up was
this
uh writing r on both the client and the
server of course you can use HTML if you
want to but
this is pretty much
what we have today in shiny
so with this idea in hand
we spent a frantic seven weeks
making shiny uh into a proof of concept
that we could present at JSM
and seven weeks later this is what we
had this is the demo that we uh
displayed at JSM and we had settled on a
tagline that was easily create
interactive web applications in R
without needing to know HTML JavaScript
and CSS
so now we knew that it was possible
but now what
now to me
my ambitions for this was gee I hope
someone uses this and likes it
and JJ being JJ said why shouldn't all
our users be making apps and why
shouldn't shiny be the way that they
make them
so the three of us got to work Winston
Chang joined the company uh just a very
short time after JSM and we got to work
working on shiny and in order for shiny
to be a success for it to have an impact
on the our community
there were three big questions
that we had to answer and the answers
had to be yes across the board
the first question
can we even build this in R we did the
proof of concept can we take it to
production
because the conventional wisdom was that
R is a language for stats not web
Frameworks
secondly are our users ready to write
web apps
because writing web apps is very
different than data analysis there are
different muscles that you need to use
and shiny in particular was going to ask
people to learn Concepts that nobody
almost nobody had seen before
were our users ready to do that
and the third was would the r Community
respond
in 2012 I mean if you weren't there it
might be a little bit hard to picture
but
uh we were nobodies we were unknowns and
not only that our studio it was almost a
little suspicious what we were doing
here's this like weirdly fully formed
IDE
a that they don't charge for
there's no pro version
they're working on it full time
so people were wondering what's the
catch
and especially in a community or the
where the GPL and and open source was so
much part of the ethos uh we wondered
are people going to accept us
I want to tackle these questions one by
one a little bit out of order the first
one being are our users ready to write
web apps and what we learned was this
our users are not afraid to learn I mean
think of who you need to be to even be
considering learning shiny
okay you learn statistics
you know about visualization you learn
to code
you know get
you probably know the grammar of
graphics
yeah I think they can sit through a few
tutorials and read some reference
documentation our users were not afraid
and continue to not be afraid
and our users were and are incredibly
motivated by what shiny offers them we
did not have to sell very hard for
people to realize
shiny was not just one more tool in
their toolbox but it was a force
multiplier for everything that they can
already do in R because it meant those
existing skills
could be exposed to a broader audience
than they could otherwise accomplish
and
shiny produced mic drop moments for our
users I'm going to go out a little bit
on a limb here
and tell me if this sounds familiar I I
heard multiple stories of people going
into a conference room with their shiny
at and leaving Jaws on the floor
they're gonna go out on a limb can I see
a show of hands anyone have this
experience written a shiny app that yeah
see I'm not making it up
and that's a huge motivator for people
and something about shiny feels Within
Reach to our users even though there are
a lot of Concepts that you need to learn
somehow it feels like
we wrote this for you
we wrote this expecting you to come
along and learn it and that felt
different than typescript and react in
these other web Technologies where it
felt like this was really for somebody
else and you would have to become
somebody else to learn this set of
skills
and these things might almost seem
obvious by now but it wasn't back then
and in 2012 to 2015 there was like a
Cambrian explosion of reactive
Frameworks in all different languages
and most of them are forgotten
because most of them didn't find a user
base that was motivated by what they had
to offer or they couldn't make it past
the learning curve
so I just want to be clear
I don't take this for granted it's
amazing it's amazing that things worked
out this way
so the question we had going into this
is are users ready to write web apps
and the conclusion that I've come to is
that R has the best audience for shiny
it's perfect
the next question
would the r Community respond
and instead of telling you let me just
show you
this is just a list off the top of my
head the other day of some of the
many amazing packages that people have
released that are built on top of shiny
and enhance the capabilities of shiny in
some way and I know that a lot of you in
this audience are using these packages
and the authors of some of these
packages are here in the audience as
well
maintaining an open source package that
people actually use is not an easy feat
and a lot of people put a lot of time
into the packages not only on this list
but on all the ones that I don't have
room to list here
and again
I don't take that lightly that is a huge
uh vote of confidence in the work that
we're doing and the foundation that
we've built
so I'm so grateful to all these people
and
uh there's a there's a GitHub user
called Nan X stats that has a document
called awesome shinyextensions.github
and this is a list of just a whole bunch
of packages written in r that extend or
enhance shiny in some way
there's a few
again it's humbling to see how much time
and energy people have invested in
trying to make shiny better
and as Hadley said
writing books Ain't Easy
I'm sorry this is unscripted but
I believe the first advice you gave me
about book writing
was I asked how does it work with
getting a publisher or whatever
and he said step one
write a book
step two get it published
there's no step three
yeah
not great advice so
uh I'm astounded that there are I mean
not just three but there there are
several more complete books that people
have written about shiny and again
knowing how hard it is to put together a
book I'm in awe that there are people
who are doing this
for shiny
and I don't think we can really talk
about the shiny Community without
mentioning Eric Nance
is Eric an answer around here somewhere
oh there he is
yeah
Eric Nance might be the biggest
cheerleader for shiny inside or outside
of our studio
and among the many contribution
contributions that Eric has made is uh
he currently has this shiny developer
Series going uh it is what 30 plus
episodes and Counting of really
interesting and deep conversations with
a very interesting uh and deep people
around the shiny community so I
definitely encourage you to check that
out
and there are so many other ways people
contribute
that are not necessarily in those
categories
every GitHub issue or PR it takes time
and energy to put together replexes to
put together patches and I appreciate
every single one
every year we hold a shiny contest and
I'm Blown Away by the amount of care
people put into crafting these
submissions it clearly means a lot to
people
blog posts conference talks workshops
there's so much content that people put
together about shiny and it is not easy
there are entire uh tutorials that were
created by people in the community Zev
Ross here in the front row created a
tutorial talking about how to use shiny
from scratch uh with a bent towards
ggplot and that got a lot of people into
shiny in the beginning
uh Absalon are the Athlon guys here
the absolute folks yep
they did a shiny conference didn't see
that coming
so
I'm sorry that you know it's been 10
years please can you just give me this
um I'm so grateful to all these people
and all the different kinds of
contributions they've made and because I
have the attention of this whole room
and I know a lot of the people in the
community are in this room can we just
take a second and all say thank you to
all these people
[Applause]
so if the question was will the our
community respond
I I can't either I can't even put into
words how the community has responded
and finally can we even build it in r
in 2012 you might have heard things like
R is a DSL
a domain specific language
the alternative to R isn't python or C
sharp it's SAS
you never use R4 you know a web server
these are real quotes from a real talk
that was given by John D cook
I go to 2012. and this is not to pick on
John D cook these were totally
reasonable statements at the time
and what we found was not just that it
was going to be possible to do this in
our
but it was bizarrely good as a host
language for shiny bizarrely good and I
feel like that's sort of an
extraordinary claim so I will provide
provide some evidence
it's going to get a little bit geeky so
just be ready for the shift in tone
a lot of languages
have positional and named arguments
programming languages a positional Arc
like you see here is like X right
there's no name you just put it with the
right number of commas and it gets
matched up
and then you have named arguments where
you specify exactly what parameter
you're passing height equals 20 in this
case
and tons of languages tons of languages
have both positional and named arguments
but what almost none of them have none
that are in current use that I could
find
R allows the named arguments to be
passed first
super random weird Quirk Nobody Does
this this is not considered a best
practice
python doesn't do it Ruby doesn't do it
C sharp doesn't do it none of these
languages that have both named and
positional arcs let you uh put them in
this order
and by the way in R you can put it in
whatever order you can mix them it's R
you know
and this matters for shiny it matters
for shiny because a lot of what the UI
layer of shiny does is Express HTML and
think about how you express HTML if
you're familiar with HTML if not
hopefully you'll be able to follow along
an HTML tag really lets you express
three things the tag itself in this case
on the outside we have a UL tag for an
unordered list
secondly the attributes for that tag
describing uh well attributes about the
tag in this case it's saying that this
unordered list is for the purpose of
navigation
and third and last you have children
what are the things that are contained
inside of this tag but this order is the
right order this is the way we think
about it right what am I making a UL
what are the attributes of that UL it's
a nav and then what's inside the UL
children
so if this is the structure we're aiming
at how closely can we match that in r
pretty close as it turns out pretty
close
it almost looks like we've just taken
away some angle brackets and added some
parentheses and some commas sorry about
the commas
it's the same order
UL
first
attribute second
third
and it's only because we're allowed to
put the named arguments that we're using
for attributes first
so just to take a language at random
let's talk about python python has named
arguments but they have to go last
so we end up with tag first
attributes at the bottom
and then all the children
and that is a problem because it adds
all this space that you have to look
past
in order to find out what kind of a UL
you're creating and this example is just
12 lines but you can imagine if this is
a production dashboard it might be
screenfuls that you have to Traverse
so I don't want to uh to to put up the
weakest straw man possible so let's
steal manit a little bit right
so um
here is one option that you could use in
Python to improve the situation you
could get rid of named arguments
altogether and express everything with
positional arguments and you could do
that you could put
a dictionary at the top similar to like
a named list I guessed
and uh this would work it adds some
curly braces it adds some quotation
marks so it's not perfect but it
certainly works I'm not gonna argue it
doesn't work I would call this maybe 85
percent as good as what you can do in r
the other way you go in Python is to go
all named arguments so you don't pass
children as unnamed arguments instead
you make
a named argument called children and
give it a list
again the details here aren't important
the point is that
well the point is it's worse I guess
that's the point
and this one to me is worse than the
previous one because it actually pushes
the code off the page we've added a line
a vertical line and a level of
indentation for uh for each level of
children at this point
okay
and also switching from UI to reactivity
non-standard evaluation ended up being
weirdly bizarrely good for reactive
programming not something that we had
anticipated
this is what my sort of if I could wave
at magic wand and have a language to
express reactivity and it might look
something like this I want a language
keyword for the word reactive that's an
important concept
I want to attach a code block to that
keyword
and then reading something out of a
reactive expression like read data say I
want a star operator sort of like
dereferencing a pointer and C
so this is kind of what you know if I
got my wish this is what a perfect
language for reactivity would look like
and let's see what we have in r
it's pretty close
in Python we have to go a different way
python does not have non-standard
evaluation so you can't pass a bare
block of code
to uh to a function and expect it to be
anything but a value by the time you the
function gets at it
instead in Python you have to write a
function a named function and then you
have to apply reactivity to it now again
I don't want to leave you with a straw
man so here's the Steel Man
python has a few tricks of its own up
its sleeve and this is called a
decorator and you know what this is not
bad I'll say this is maybe like 90 is
good as r
ough
um I still don't love that it's a
function it feels like you made a
function and then you made it reactive
and I really prefer how it looks in R
where it sort of feels like you
constructed a reactive
but I'm not going to argue that this
doesn't uh work and doesn't have appeal
to people who come from this tradition
Okay so can we even build it in r
R is the best language for shining I
will die on this hill R is the best
language for Chinese
so those three big questions were
answered
can we even build it in r
is the best language for shiny are you
are our users ready to write web apps R
has the best audience for Shining
and will the our community respond to
almost an absurd degree you have
responded
so yes
shiny has been a success
so I hope that I have convinced you
or at least I've convinced you that I am
convinced that R is the best language
for shiny
but you know what they say about python
python is the second best language for
anything
python is the second best language for
anything and that is not an insult that
is a compliment
that quote was popularized by Dan
Callahan at pycon 2018 during a keynote
he said python is the second best
language for anything and that is an
amazing aspiration
because it means that whatever domain
you're operating in whatever weird new
technique in Computing you're interested
in
there's a pretty good chance that you
can stitch something together in Python
and it might not be the very best
version or the very best expression of
that idea but it will be available to
you without going somewhere else and
there is undoubtedly power in that
so introducing shiny for python
like 45 of you are real excited
here is an app running in shiny for
python
this is sort of our July 31st 2012
moment for shiny for R that's about
where we are today with shiny for python
I don't expect you to be able to read
this code
but
uh if you could
and you know shiny for R and you know a
little bit of python this is going to
look pretty familiar
there are a lot of Concepts that carry
through between the two even though we
are dealing with two separate languages
and the server side uh is filled with
the same kind of reactive Concepts that
you're used to from shiny for r
and before we go further I have to warn
you
this is an alpha
and it's especially Alpha because we did
all this work in secret
and uh we're not used to doing that none
of us really like it we're really happy
to not have to do it after today
um so we are not ready to call something
uh out of alpha until the community has
had a chance to bang on it and we still
reserve the right to change the API so I
want to I'm going to give you that
warning
our design Philosophy for shiny for
python
was that it's very similar conceptually
to shiny for R and that wasn't
necessarily a first principle that we
started with we were open to changing
our ideas as we moved from our uh to
Python and vice versa but
I think what we found was a lot of the
trade-offs that we had made in R were
pretty Universal and they felt pretty
good in Python but it's not a slavishly
literal report from R we don't want
shiny for python to feel like it was
written by our users we wanted to feel
idiomatically like python
so to give an example of what I mean
when I say uh
you know python is the second best
language for anything
I tapped our resident astrophysicist
Dr Julia silgie not a joke
um
and I asked her you know I I hear python
maybe he's big in astronomy is there
something we could do with a shiny app
for that and she had this idea for an
air mass calculator
and long story short this lets you
provide a list of astronomical objects
you're interested in observing on a
certain day and from a certain location
on Earth
and this calculator will tell you what
times of night are optimal for viewing
that object
including
uh
I'm not astronomer uh
how much air lies along your line of
sight between you and the object you're
viewing because depending on its angle
from The Horizon you're going through a
different amount of atmosphere so that's
what this air mass calculator is showing
you
super easy to do
because of Astral pie
and super easy to turn into this app
because of shiny
so shiny for python again Alpha it is
available now if you go to
shiny.rstudio.com Pi
you'll find lots of documentation there
are examples there's articles there's
API Docs
and I want to talk a little bit about
editor support
we expect that most people are probably
going to be writing these things in vs
code and we've written an extension for
authoring shiny for Python and vs code
if you use something else like pycharm
or Jupiter lab that should work too
we're a pretty standard python web
framework in that respect
our studio IDE is going to get basic
support for shiny for python apps in the
next release
uh that'll be mostly in the form of a
run app button
and if you are using our studio
workbench to have our studio on a server
then the vs code and jupyter lab
versions that are uh run on our studio
workbench work great if you have the
current release of our studio workbench
spotted Wake Robin
now because shiny for python is shiny we
have to talk about deployment options
and I'm so pleased
I'm so pleased to tell you this is
working today on shinyapps iO you can
deploy shiny for python apps today
our studio connect already supports
shiny for python in its current version
the one that came out in uh earlier this
month
uh it's just not documented
at our request
and rs RS connect python is the CLI tool
you use to deploy to those uh servers
and as of today
um assuming everything went well
okay I'm getting the nod
yes uh this is uh available now in the
in arts connect python
and uh of course as
as JJ said this morning we never want to
lock up your work in proprietary
Solutions so we do always have an open
source
um option available shiny server open
source
oh
it'll be fully released when I get back
to my hotel room there was one more
button I've
listen guys it's a long talk and I was
very nervous
foreign
okay uh instructions for all this is uh
they're all available on the shiny for
python site under the deploy tab
uh there is one more deployment option
for shiny for python
you can deploy it to a static web server
wait what
um and I'm sorry I'm going to have to
leave you with that teaser because
Winston Chang is going to talk about
this uh tomorrow at 11 30 a.m running
shiny without a server
all right
I gotta say this is
I mean this is a magic trick of Our Own
uh when Winston suggested
this technique
uh I actually told him not to do it I
said you were wasting your time and he
proved me wrong within 48 hours so uh it
should be a talk to remember
I do have to give a little caveats some
restrictions apply not all absolutely
eligible serious side effects may occur
must be 18 years older
you don't need to be 18 years or older
but I'm not joking about the other ones
uh there there are caveats uh this is
not going to be a universal model for
how we deploy uh shiny for python but
uh the fact that this is even possible
is incredible and I think for definitely
some of you in this room uh it's going
to be a powerful way to deploy shiny for
python s
now I want to make it clear
that the future of shiny is not python
the future of shiny is r and python
and I don't want you to think that we uh
only have goodies
for uh for the python Community today
again
a lot of this work was done in secret so
we have to consider it Alpha
but man the things
you might have known that shiny for
python was coming I don't think you know
that this next one is coming
a visual editor for shiny UI
now some of you that have known me for a
long time might be a little bit
surprised I mean this has been suggested
many times and uh I have shot it down
sometimes in sort of a principled tone
um
so uh Nick Strayer is going to talk
about why we think that this is the
right time for us to to do something
like this and how we avoided the
pitfalls that I was so worried about
when it came to visual editors
Greg swinehart is a developer who's
worked with and for our studio for gosh
like 10 years now and recently Greg
joined the shiny team to help us help
you make better designed better looking
apps
uh so uh it's early stages but Greg is
going to talk about both some of his own
design principles that come to mind as
he looks at shiny apps and how they can
be better and also some of the
components that we're creating uh that
will help make it easier for you to fall
into a pit of success when it comes to
your designs
and finally Barrett schlurky is going to
be talking about shiny Test 2
this is not secret this is up on cran
and shiny Test 2 is a fundamental part
of the shiny stack for anybody who cares
about robustness and uh and keeping
uh their apps bug free
it's really difficult to work
and it takes a lot of patience and it's
not particularly glamorous and I think
Barrett schlerty I can't think of a
better person uh to tackle these kinds
of hard problems
I'm sorry I can't resist this can anyone
dead lift more than 503 pounds in this
room
and Barrett silke is also the strongest
person at our studio conf
he's also a new dad but there's lots of
new dads that's 503 pounds that's
ridiculous
um
this is team shiny
this is the harder I knew this was gonna
be the hardest part of my talk
um it's my favorite slide and it was the
hardest thing to come up with anything
to say I'm so grateful to this team I'm
so grateful for the work that we've done
together over the last year
all right
thank you very much if you want to learn
more about uh shiny for pi uh shiny for
python uh you can go to this link or use
the QR code and don't forget these talks
tomorrow by shiny team members
thank you so much for 10 great years of
shiny
thank you
thank you
thanks Joe uh thanks everyone uh well uh
while we wait for our questions on the
slide I had one more comment for Joe
because during this talk I remembered I
think it was in 2012 like Joe it must
have been like a user or JSM like Joe
was telling me about this idea he had to
do like a web app a web application
framework in R and I was like in my head
yeah Joe that's just what I mean it's an
art development a web development
framework so another case whereas are
very very wrong
so our first question for you Joe uh how
did you come up with the name shiny
yes so the the name shiny comes from a
show called Firefly
um a few months before shiny uh you know
became a thing I was laying sick in bed
and I watched the whole series Firefly
for the first time and they used the
word shiny to mean good
um they'll say yeah I'm feeling shiny
yeah this job is going really shiny and
I just thought like oh that's I liked
how they just sort of slip that in all
casual and I thought that'd be a cool
name for a project someday
um the the day that I was creating the
GitHub repo
for the first commit of what was to
become shiny
on GitHub there's a little name
suggestor right it says like having
trouble thinking of a name it's blah
blah blah and it's three segments I
don't remember the first segment but it
was like maybe it was something like
ninja octocat shiny and I was like all
right that's a sign from God I'm it's
shiny that's what it's going to be
oh I know I've asked you this question
myself what do you think of people
calling shiny ah shiny
uh yeah I think maybe Dean Italy
popularized this uh and just felt like
it hates more clear and he really was
successful in popularizing it and I
think for people in internal to our
studio they'd frequently ask hey is it
our shiny or is it shiny and I said it's
shiny it's not our shiny it's just shiny
and so I think like all of us sort of
developed a little bit of an aversion to
our shiny but now that they're shiny for
python
it's going to be hard not to call it our
shiny so I'm I've made my piece with it
so what about obviously other similar
Frameworks like Dash and streamlit exist
why why shiny for python yeah totally uh
that's a valid question and it's a
really interesting question we didn't
have to face with shiny for r
um
I think that there uh as these
Frameworks are coming out we looked at
them each one of them and we were
curious
um not even from a competitive point of
view but just out of curiosity what were
their approaches what trade-offs had
they chosen
and it turned out that despite the
proliferation of these kinds of web
Frameworks in Python all the trade-offs
that they chose were actually quite
different than what we were doing with
shiny and I think the kinds of apps that
I see people build people in this room
a lot of them would actually be
difficult to build given the trade-offs
inherent in those other uh you know this
is not like a python conference it's not
posit con it's you know it's it's our
studio card so I I don't want to belabor
it but I do want to say that
um there are real differences and I
think that there is room for uh we think
that there's room for something new in
the in the python world
somewhat related what about Pi script
oh the the new uh thing
yes so Pi script uh is a really
interesting piece of technology that
sort of goes the other way it lets you
take an HTML page and you know that
might have JavaScript might have
whatever in it and it lets you embed
python
Snippets of code into your uh into your
JavaScript apps basically I think they
want to replace JavaScript as the
language of directly manipulating
web apps so that replaces one part of
the stack it replaces the language Java
script with the language python so I
think that's a that's an interesting
Endeavor and uh certainly very
impressive technically and uh quite
different than I think what we're trying
to do which is
um
to go from Python and sort of relieve
you from think having to have to think
about the entire stack so the
orchestration of how data moves back and
forth between the server and the client
there's just a lot of things that are
part of our stack that uh Pi script is
just out of it's out of scope
now uh you mentioned that uh we might be
able to run python
shiny for python
with outer server what about shiny for r
uh we sure hope
we sure hope so
um the thing is that right now
the technology that this
is it okay if I say the word
uh this approach that we're taking for
running in the browser is called wasm
and python is the second best language
for wasn't yeah
those guys every time yeah they're the
second best language for Watson yeah
rust is probably number one
um
so the question really is about
is R gonna have wasm and the answer is
why don't you answer that
uh yeah so that that is something that
we're going to be working on uh you
might want to uh George Stagg who's
recently joined our Studios giving a
lightning talk about this so we're you
know actively working to bring Wes and
far so you can take any uh application
and compile it to JavaScript basically
I feel like we just did a really bad
version of like Winston's and George's
talk
sorry you should you should uh you
should check them out it's gonna be
pretty exciting okay I've got a high
stress question for you but I'm going to
follow it up with a low stress question
so when will the book that covers all of
these exciting new features be out Joe
uh whenever Hadley needs a new bike yeah
[Applause]
uh what would it be possible to use both
R and python within a single app
uh could you use both R and python in a
single app I mean I suppose you could do
something with reticulate or you you we
know you can because people do uh use
reticulate with Chinese for R and um I'm
sure the reverse works as well
um but yeah not definitely not something
that we
um have thought a lot about in building
shiny for python
how about other packages in the kind of
China ecosystem like shiny Test 2 and
HTML tools are you going to bring those
to python as well
yeah um
we sure hope so
uh again this is the 2012 moment of
shiny for python uh anything's possible
are those three big questions going to
be answered the same way in the python
community
I nobody knows so I think it would
probably be premature for me to stand
here and say that all these things are
going to appear but it is certainly Our
intention if we're successful in the
fullness of time for shiny for python to
be a mature and complete stack in the
same way that shiny for R is
so so following up on that uh is the
plan to have the the features developed
at the same pace for both R and python
in the future oh the feature be
developed in the same pace
um certainly for features where python
is catching up to R naturally it's going
to go much faster in Python than it ever
did in R because we're doing everything
for a second time
uh it is just much easier when you have
solved a problem once in terms of new
features we haven't really talked about
this but I wouldn't want to commit to
any kind of artificial artificially
enforced parity I mean I think part of
the point of what we're trying to do
here is to not focus on keeping these
things equal we want them to both be as
good as they can be for their respective
communities and we might make a
different set of trade-offs if we
expected that people were going to
switch back and forth every day but uh
and I no doubt there will be some people
who do that I mean maybe even people in
this room who do that but I think we
really want to optimize for if you're
spending a lot of time in shiny for R it
feels good as an R user and if you spend
a lot of time in China for python it
feels good as a python user so we are
going to try to make each of those
Frameworks as good as they can be
okay so we'll finish up with a
potentially dangerous question and bear
in mind we only have three minutes left
so uh someone would like to know don't
go into too much technical detail what
sort of bike did you build me
I I know nothing about the bag except
it's awesome so this is definitely a
joke question
uh it is an all City space horse it's a
steel light Touring bike
and um I blinged it out it was
pretty spectacular did you show a
picture I couldn't see no I didn't show
a picture but uh I can I'll tweet up
I'll tweet a picture so people can
appreciate it yeah
I'll tweet the picture
so thank you Joe uh thank you all and uh
enjoy the rest of the conference
[Music]